today we're talking about ubisoft nfts
another ghost recon and a warzone nerf
following yesterday's news that ghost
recon breakpoint would no longer receive
support many wondered what that meant
for ubisoft quartz the studio's nft
project that first launched in
breakpoint well a quick look at the
court's website shows that ubisoft seems
to have plans to continue the site
thanks players who claim their in-game
nfts and goes on to say quote stay tuned
for more updates with features to the
platform and future drops coming with
other games the last batch of nfts for
breakpoint released on march 17th and
since then the studio has been fairly
quiet about where the exclusive digits
would appear next my bet is that they
stick with ghost recon and they pop up
in the next ghost recon which apparently
isn't ghost recon frontline anymore
that's right a new ghost recon game is
reportedly in development and has been
for over a year according to kotaku the
next mainline ghost recon game could
launch as early as fiscal year 2023 and
is codenamed over not much other
information about this ghost recon is
currently available last year ubisoft
revealed ghost recon frontline a
free-to-play live service game kotago
reports that a negative internal play
test earlier this year has caused the
project to reset and so it will likely
not launch soon another ubisoft project
codenamed pathfinder is reportedly in
the works as well according to the
reports it's similar to ubisoft's almost
dead battle royale hyperscape but more
cartoony hyperscape and ghost recon
breakpoint weren't all that well
received and it seems like ubisoft is
looking to move on as hyperscape servers
are shutting down later this month and
breakpoint isn't getting any new content
switching gears to call of duty now call
of duty warzone sniper rifles have felt
pretty powerful in season 2 but players
should expect some weapon balancing
changes in an attempt to level the
playing field in season 3. the news of
the upcoming sniper nerf for season 3
comes from ted timmons who works on
warzone as raven software's senior
creative director on april 5th timmins
was interviewed on a twit stream hosted
by complexity's content creators known
as bacca bros after a discussion of
overpowered snipers and the increase in
sniper use on caldera timmins confirmed
changes would be coming to warzone
sniper rifles the developer's response
to the sniper issues was to say that
raven software's weapons team is
listening and the team does plan on
shifting the meta for sniper rifles
timmons said quote i think we would all
agree it's long overdue the sniper meta
hasn't changed in what feels like
forever however timmins explained they
wanted to have more of a conversation
closer to season 3 as the developer
didn't want to gas up the change while
not knowing the full extent of the
upcoming weapon balancing regardless
players can expect some form of sniper
nerve to arrive for season 3. timmons
also discussed a recent raven software
interview where the developer again
confirmed that warzone's pass for dansk
map would not be returning for map
rotation looks like players will need to
be content with caldera and rebirth
island maps for now or at least until
activision releases war zone 2 which is
being built from the ground up but hit
the comment section let me know what you
had for breakfast this morning i'll see
you tomorrow